casi un millón de brasileños firmaron la
nueva carta por la democracia
distintos sectores Unidos en la facultad
de derecho de Sao Paulo para denunciar
al presidente Yair bolso
la democracia está destruida en Brasil
él nuestro presidente está destruyendo
todas las instituciones
estamos aquí estamos aquí Unidos para
defender la democracia estamos aquí para
defender la legislación electoral la
justicia electoral y el sistema
electoral con urnas electrónicas
estas manifestaciones prodemocracias se
producen a menos de dos meses de las
elecciones presidenciales en las que
bolsonaros se enfrenta al ex presidente
Lula da Silva el actual presidente
arremetió en contra del documento
creo que la carta por la democracia
leída en la micareta del partido de los
trabajadores tenía alguna de sus páginas
arrancadas especialmente las partes que
debían repudiar el apoyo incluso
financiero a dictaduras como la de Cuba
Nicaragua y Venezuela
la preocupación de algunos brasileños
surge las declaraciones de Jair
bolsonaro y de los funcionarios de su
gobierno como el ministro de defensa
Paulo nogueira quien envió una
comunicación oficial de urgencia a las
autoridades electorales en las que
reclama acceso para las fuerzas armadas
del código fuente de las urnas
electrónicas tras la desconfianza
evolucionaron el sistema electrónico de
votación según encuestas la diferencia
entre ambos candidatos en el estado
paulista es de tan solo dos puntos
porcentuales con ventaja para Lula
alcanzando el 37%.